The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So today what
we're going to talk
about, we're going
to move from the
descriptive discussions
of organizational
decision-making
to a couple of prescriptive
sessions, which
is if you're running an energy
business, how do you do it?
One of the things,
as this indicates
that we talked
about you should do,
you should be doing
present value analysis,
net present value analysis
of investment opportunities.
But that's not strategy.
So today and next
time, we're going
to be talking about strategy.
We'll talk about industry
attractiveness briefly,
kinds of strategies and niches
within industries, and then
the Husky case.
Wednesday, Don Lessard's going
to be here and explore with you
business models, particularly
in innovative segments.
So project by project, net
present value isn't strategy.
If a firm accepts every proposal
with a net present value,
a positive net present
value, the result
is likely to be very
incoherent and unmanageable.
The Brealey piece is sort of
a finance person's skepticism.
The first thing you
note is you only
see proposals with
positive net present value.
If someone likes a
project, it turns out
it has a positive
net present value.
So what they propose, and
we'll explore a little bit,
is thinking about disequilibria,
thinking about will it last.
It has a net present
value because we're
cheaper than they are.
OK, why are we
cheaper than they are?
We can buy materials
more cheaply than they.
Why?
Will it last?
Annika and I saw,
before vacation,
a very detailed analysis
of US versus Chinese
photovoltaic
manufacturing costs.
It concluded that the
big Chinese advantage
was they could get materials
and supplies 25% cheaper.
And the first question is, why?
Is that going to last?
The people who'd done
the study hadn't quite
inquired into that, and said it
was superior bargaining power.
Superior bargaining
power doesn't last.
So first point in the
Brealey et al. piece
is skepticism about
present value.
Porter's paper is in
a way more profound,
and really does
deserve a serious read.
Strategy is what you won't do.
What is it you won't
do as a company?
Someone walks in the
door with a project
with a positive
net present value.
When do you just say,
no, you're right,
that's a positive
net present value.
We're not going to do it.
The argument is this--
if you're doing the same thing
your competitors are, and there
are a bunch of them,
you're in a wonderful world
of perfect competition.
We all enjoy that.
It's in the textbooks.
It's easy to analyze.
And it's no fun.
You don't make any money,
particularly if there
are opportunities to innovate.
You have to innovate just to
cover your cost of capital.
There's a little quote
from Warren Buffett, which
I think still holds true, that
since the dawn of aviation
the total profits earned by
airlines adds up to zero.
Airlines have gotten
enormously more efficient.
They've done enormous
things for transportation
for the country as
a whole, but they
haven't made any money,
because mostly they're
all doing the same thing.
And there are a bunch of them.
And there's no
differentiation or stickiness.
So the first lesson
is, if you're
running a company you
don't want to be there.
As Porter points out, if
you're in that situation--
I mean, airlines have
improved efficiency enormously
over the years.
Fuel costs are down.
Electronic reservation
systems, baggage
handling-- much more efficient
than they used to be,
and they're still
not making any money
because they're all doing it.
And if you don't innovate
and improve, you lose.
Andrew?
AUDIENCE: I was just--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Just
drying your nail polish?
OK, good.
It's important to have it dry.
So lesson one is you
don't want to do that.
Lesson two is sort of the
obvious counterpoint, which
is when you set up
a business, you'd
like to be doing something
that's of value to somebody
that can't be easily imitated.
The buzzword is
"sustainable advantage."
So the notion that Chinese
photovoltaics will always
be cheaper because
Chinese bargaining power
enables them to get silicon
25% cheaper than US firms--
that doesn't wash.
If that's what's going on,
that's not sustainable.
If there is some cost advantage
in silicon production,
that's more interesting.
But if all you know
is it's cheaper,
and all you hear is "bargaining
power," that's not sustainable.
So if strategy is
what you don't do,
and it needs to be something
that can't easily be imitated,
how about the question
I posed there--
does MIT have a strategy?
If so, what is it?
Or what are elements of it?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hands-on learning.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Hands-on learning.
OK, what does that rule out?
It's an element of what
MIT is about, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] You have
to limit the amount of people
that you let in,
because you can't
have 50,000 people [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
So it's a high cost strategy.
What does it say about the
kinds of things you teach?
Medical school has
hands-on learning.
And MIT doesn't have
a medical school.
Simpler question-- Caroline,
what's Wellesley's strategy?
Does Wellesley have a strategy?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
to educate women.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Educate women in everything?
Does Wellesley have a
big engineering school?
Liberal arts-- focuses on
women, focuses on liberal arts,
doesn't offer graduate
degrees, stay small.
That's pretty easy.
What about MIT?
It's more than just
hands-on learning.
MIT doesn't have a law school.
Harvard has a law school.
Harvard has had a law
school for a long time.
Presumably those are
strategic differences.
Yes, somebody actually
sat down and said,
should MIT have a law school?
No, MIT shouldn't.
That decision has been looked
at several times in history.
Why do you think?
AUDIENCE: So they can focus
on being the best in science
and engineering.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It focuses
on science and engineering,
and things that complement
and work with it.
So does economics make sense?
Yeah, it does,
historically it does.
One of the early
presidents of MIT
was the founder of the
American Economic Association,
so somebody thought
it made sense.
We've done business
for a long time,
almost since the start
of the institute.
How about linguistics?
Why do we do linguistics?
AUDIENCE: I've
heard it's largely
because of Noam Chomsky, because
he developed the [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah, I
think that's the right answer.
I mean, my sense is a
whole bunch of decisions
have been made that a
whole bunch of areas
will be basically
service departments,
so that we can actually
give a rounded education.
And into that-- history, we
don't do advanced degrees
in history.
And sociology we don't have.
Psychology is very focused.
But into languages and
linguistics stumbles
Noam Chomsky, and you say, oh,
my god, what an opportunity
this is, and so you build on it.
But it's not a big department,
and it's pretty focused.
And we don't have a lot
of modern languages.
We don't have a
French department.
Spanish department.
There's probably a French
department at Wellesley, yes?
Yeah.
We don't have one.
So MIT does have a strategy.
It's not perfectly--
not easily written down,
but the strategic
descriptions have
to do with science,
engineering, and related fields,
and complementary fields.
Wellesley's is pretty clear.
Harvard's is we do
almost everything.
We're a full-service supplier.
It is interesting,
Harvard doesn't
have a veterinary school.
I'm not quite sure why, but they
have just about everything else
you could think about.
I don't think they have
Library Science, but just about
everything else.
So those are strategies.
MIT has faced the
possibility of a law school.
MIT could make money
with a law school,
has decided not to
do it, has decided
not to have a medical school.
That's a harder call.
That's a more interesting
call, but has decided
not to do a medical school.
Strategy is, to an important
extent, what you won't do.
And you could certainly do a
net present value calculation
for the MIT Medical
School and come out
with a positive and
also social impact.
You could also talk
about a law school
with heavy focus on patent
law and related intellectual
property fields, which
does, to a certain extent,
complement, but also distracts.
And that's a strategic choice.
So universities, like all
kinds of other organizations,
need to make strategic choices.
Another strategy might be
we'll do almost anything that
will turn a profit.
And you see some
places look like that.
MIT very much doesn't.
So if you're really thinking
about a sustainable advantage
of some sort, a
coherent strategy,
you have to consider
the next bullet, or not.
What the next bullet says
is, when the slide works,
you have to think
about complementarities
or fit among
investment projects.
Meantime, I'm
going to figure out
why this works or
this doesn't work.
The nice piece that we had--
tech support, please.
I have a frozen
machine at the moment.
There are nice examples
in Porter about IKEA
and about Southwest
Airlines, and they're
great examples of taking on
things that fit together.
Southwest Airlines
doesn't offer food.
Southwest Airlines flies
out of small airports.
one kind of airplane.
All those things fit together--
low cost, convenient.
You could make a case
that gee, if we had more--
oh, and you don't book
through online services.
You had a hammer?
AUDIENCE: No, I
have to [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
OK, thank you.
All right, we're going to try
to do this without slides.
It's going to be good.
The examples there are
things that fit together.
You could imagine Southwest
doing a calculation,
and saying, well, if we used
online booking services,
we'd get more volume.
And that'll cost us x percent.
And you could imagine
saying, well, it'll
increase our costs a little
bit, but it'll pay off.
They have a relentless
focus on costs.
We're not going to do it.
We're not going to have
assigned seats-- that takes
time and extra gate personnel.
We're not going to do online
reservations, because that'll
increase our costs.
We're going to be
low cost, convenient.
We're not going to have
different kinds of planes,
even though on some
routes we might
want to fly larger
planes, because that'll
increase our costs.
So Southwest thinks about how
its decisions fit together.
Similarly, the example of
IKEA, which you all probably
know better than I do, but you
go into a traditional furniture
store, you can get all
kinds of different things.
You order them-- many
fabrics, many styles.
It takes six to eight weeks.
Some slave in North Carolina
makes it, and it's shipped up.
IKEA doesn't offer that,
doesn't offer the customization.
It offers cost, convenience,
and a certain look.
That's what it focuses on.
All of its decisions
aim for that.
So that's a coherent strategy.
You don't just
take anything with
a positive net present value.
You ask how does it fit with
what we're trying to do?
How does it fit with
An MIT law school might
have positive benefits.
How does it fit
with the main focus?
How would the law school faculty
interact with other faculty?
Would it be the
kinds of people who
will fit well on the campus?
How would law students relate?
That's not to say that
that's an obvious question.
I always think a more
interesting strategic choice
is, should MIT invest
more in public policy?
We have STS and so forth.
We don't have the
Kennedy School.
You could imagine
a case being made
for a serious public
policy school focused
on science and technology.
That case hasn't been made.
And that's a money
loser, by the way,
but it might have
other strategic value.
Any hope?
AUDIENCE: They have to reboot
the machine [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: They
have to reboot the machine.
OK.
We now go to blackboard
for the next slide.
The next slide has to do with--
and I can't do blackboard
with a jacket on.
So the next slide has to do
with industry attractiveness.
So as I said, this is about
thinking about what activities
you are doing.
What are you offering customers?
If you're offering
customers the same things
as a lot of competitors,
then you can be really good,
but unless there's
some way you're
better that can't be imitated,
you've got a problem.
So if you look at
an industry and you
ask what things affect
profits, one thing
is the intensity of competition.
Another thing is
pressure from suppliers--
I'll give you
examples in a minute.
Another thing is pressure from
buyers, substitutes, and entry.
This is an ugly version of the
famous Mike Porter Five Forces.
If you understand this fully,
you're a third of the way
through the MBA
course in strategy.
So let me try to do it quickly.
It's not very hard--
maybe only a quarter
of the way through.
Regardless of what the
supply conditions are,
and whether they're
entrants or not,
if the industry is
perfectly competitive,
nobody makes any money.
That's sort of the definition.
And obviously, competition runs
along some sort of spectrum
between a lot of small firms
beating each other's brains out
and one monopoly taking
everything there is to be had.
So this is one force that
can affect competition,
can affect profits, is the
intensity of competition
within the industry.
Another force is the existence
of close substitutes.
We all make wax paper, and we're
great wax paper manufacturers,
but plastic wrap is
eating our lunch.
And so there may be only two or
three of us making wax paper,
but with the availability
of cheap plastic wrap,
it means we have probably
declining demand.
It means we probably have a
highly elastic demand curve.
And even with a monopoly,
we can't make any money,
so close, good
substitutes erode profits.
Please have at it.
I'm a wax paper manufacturer.
There's only one of me, but
anybody and his kid sister
can make wax paper.
That's not quite right, and
it could be his kid brother,
too, don't mean to be sexist.
But if it's really
easy for competitors
to come in if anybody's
making any money,
nobody can sustain high profits.
So you look at entry when
you do an industry analysis,
is it easy for
outsiders to come in?
What are the obstacles?
Do you need
specialized knowledge?
Do you need huge capital?
What are the problems?
If there aren't any
obvious barriers--
we're making furniture
in North Carolina.
What do you need to make
furniture in North Carolina?
You need to hire
good carpenters,
and get a supply of wood,
and have some design skill.
Are those high
barriers to entry?
Probably not.
So would you expect,
even if there are only
a small number of
furniture manufacturers,
would you expect them
to make a lot of money?
Probably not.
OK, suppliers-- my
favorite example
here really is
airlines, because one
of the things that characterized
airlines, particularly
under regulation, is
very strong unions.
So while the airlines
didn't make any money,
airline employees did.
Pilots earn very high salary
for relatively little work.
Flight attendants--
this is, again,
in the days of regulation--
flight attendants
earned very high salaries.
The regulators pushed prices
up, and most of the rent,
most of the profit, went down
here to the unionized suppliers
because there was pretty
heavy competition up here.
So we had competition here,
the ability here to earn rent.
You see this in a
lot of industries
where there's relatively little
competition in the industry--
competition within the industry,
substitutes, buyers, entrants,
suppliers.
Is injection molding a good
business to be in in 1995?
Julian, why not?
AUDIENCE: Because
China does it cheaper.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
not in 1995, they didn't.
Let's stay within the bounds
of the case if we can.
Anybody else?
Charlotte.
AUDIENCE: No, because
at that point,
competitors are thinking
of ways to do things
cheaper to [INAUDIBLE]
money and also
because the buyers
were these people using
the machines that
they were making,
and the materials they
needed were in high demand,
so prices are going up.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That's the resin.
We'll come to that.
But this thing, you're
saying there's just a lot
going on here within
the industry-- very
intense computation.
What's interesting about
this is that's right.
It doesn't look like
most of that industry
is very attractive, even
though it's growing like crazy.
The industry is
growing like crazy--
it's a great
example of everybody
having to run fast to
stay in the same place,
because there's a lot of
innovation, as Charlotte says,
and if you're not
doing it, you lose.
So industries that look
like that are not uncommon.
You think about the
early days-- again,
Warren Buffett-- the
early days of automobiles.
There were hundreds of
people making automobiles.
And they were all
making great progress,
and innovating like crazy,
and automobile sales
were taking off like a
rocket, and most of them
died because they were offering
more or less the same kind
of product, doing more or less
the same things as everybody
else, and had to run
to keep in place.
So I think in terms of we hear
a little bit about buyers--
only a little bit.
One of the big bottle makers is
mentioned as a powerful buyer.
We don't know much about that.
Substitutes, we seem
to be pretty good.
This looks like an
industry people can enter.
This does not look like
a high barrier industry.
We're not told much
about that, but we don't
see much of a problem there.
There seem to be lots
of mold makers and lots
of suppliers of components.
So we don't seem to
have a problem here.
The real problem
in this industry
is here, where there's just
very intense competition,
even though there's high growth,
even though there's innovation.
Everybody is innovating.
Everybody is moving.
And everybody's running very
fast to stay in the same place.
So how do you beat this?
Well, let me talk generically,
and then we'll go to Husky.
So generically,
stepping way back,
you've got to both create
value and capture it.
So if you think
about suppliers, what
would you get for airplanes
and airline personnel?
What would you have
to pay to get a pilot
to fly as opposed to what you
do pay to get a pilot to fly--
again, in the great old
days of limited competition.
There may well be a gap between
the suppliers' opportunity
costs-- what else could they do
with their capital and labor--
and what they sell for.
That's captured by the supplier.
There better be some gap between
what buyers are willing to pay
and what they actually pay.
And the difference
is what you get
to take home, the difference
between what it actually costs
you and what you can sell.
And this is, like, yeah.
This is pretty straightforward
and pretty obvious.
But you really do need
to think through--
and I love the
animation-- you do
need to think through
who captures it.
If you go to the
airlines, there's
anomalous value created by the
airline industry, historically.
Imagine it going away.
It's not captured, by and
large, by the airline companies.
Where does it go?
Well, with the decline of
airline unions, less of it
gets captured by suppliers, and
more of it's captured by us.
If you think about the
alternative way of--
I was in Florida last week.
And driving to Florida, which
I have done, is not much fun.
So I would have been willing
to spend a lot more than it
cost me to fly.
I got a huge surplus.
I don't have the impression that
the folks supplying the airline
were getting a lot of money.
And I know the airline
wasn't getting much
in terms of captured surplus.
So the basic strategic question
is, in any kind of industry--
attractive or unattractive--
can you do this?
So where Porter is pointing,
and where this case points us,
is to ways to not
do the same thing
your competitors are doing.
What can we do differently?
Well, the first basic-- this is
sort of the Southwest strategy.
This says, we are going to drive
down costs and in a way that's
hard to imitate.
We'll talk about what
makes it hard to imitate.
We're going to drive
down costs, and maybe we
supply a somewhat
different product.
Southwest's product is not
very useful for somebody
who-- not very interesting
to somebody who always flies
first class and cares about it.
They don't do first class.
They've written that off.
They don't do frequent
flyer, I don't think.
Maybe they do.
But for a whole set
of business travelers,
they're not that attractive.
They're cheap, yeah,
but if somebody else
is paying my airfare,
that's not too attractive.
They're not convenient
because I can't book online.
I think about my own travel.
Usually somebody
else is paying and I
book online for simplicity.
I never fly Southwest because
the fare difference doesn't
bother the people who
are paying my airfare,
and online booking is
so enormously convenient
that I just do it.
So I'm not in the set of
consumers they're aiming at.
So what?
There are enough of them.
There are enough people and
enough travel occasions--
and I can imagine occasions when
I would check Southwest just
to see if they're cheaper.
That's a strategy.
That issue there is what
makes it hard to imitate.
What makes it hard to imitate?
As Charlotte pointed out in
the injection molding business,
everybody's innovating,
and in the airline
business everybody does
electronic reservations,
and everybody does this,
and everybody does that--
lots of innovation,
everybody driving down
costs-- more fuel
efficient engines,
no barriers to imitation.
United can copy
what American does.
American can copy
what United does.
There are seminars on
industry best practice.
Everybody does
You don't make any money
doing industry best practice.
You may avoid losing money.
So that's strategy one.
Can I somehow get low costs?
And I highlight this
"some consumers,"
because Southwest and IKEA
are nice examples of picking
a piece of the market which a
low-cost strategy makes sense.
Not everybody goes to IKEA.
I've never been in an
IKEA, as it happens.
But lots of people
do, and that's
enough to make them
a lot of money.
The other strategy,
not too surprisingly,
is to go the other
direction, is to find a way
to increase perceived
quality, willingness
to pay for some buyers
to justify higher prices.
What can we do to
justify higher prices?
And again, there are examples--
Mercedes Benz is a high quality.
They don't do the same
thing that everybody else
does, not the same kind of car.
It costs more.
It absolutely costs more.
In this example, the
cost is the same,
but you could still
make a lot of money
if those costs were
a little higher as
long as the differentiation
is effective.
So this kind of strategy,
you pick something
that somebody values.
Actually, the online
bookings-- well, not quite.
That's an interesting story.
You meet the needs.
You add costs.
You get premium prices--
terrific story, but it
has to be cost effective.
That is to say, you
can raise the price,
but if your costs go up by
more than the price, you lose.
And you come down
to the same issue--
is imitation difficult?
Is imitation difficult?
Again, we're going to
see this in Husky--
is imitation difficult?
There's sort of-- nice diagram--
there's sort of three
kinds of stories about ways
that imitation can be
difficult. The first
is sort of the IKEA/Southwest
up on top, the integration,
that if you have to
build the company
to deliver on a
strategy effectively,
that's, again in Porter, the
Southwest Airlines versus--
what was it, Continental Light.
So Continental decides
they can compete
with these low-cost carriers.
They'll offer a
low-cost carrier.
They won't serve meals and
they won't do assigned seats,
but they do baggage
interchange with other airlines
because they're Continental.
They do online booking
They do a variety
of other things
because they're Continental.
And they can't get the
cost down that low.
To get the cost down
that low, you've
got to integrate
the whole thing.
You've got to build an
IKEA to deliver IKEA.
You can't have an IKEA tacked
on to something else, which
means it's hard for an
existing firm to copy--
the notion that you have to
integrate the whole system.
I guess another sort
of example like that
would be Jiffy Lube or one
of the quick lube places
that used to--
you don't see them
as much as you used to--
that offers cheap oil change.
That's all they do
or all they did.
And could you imitate that?
Yeah, you could,
but you'd really
have to have the company
focused on doing just that.
You can't do cheap oil change
as part of a full service repair
shop that does other
things because you've
got all that overhead
and all of the systems
to handle everything.
If you just do oil change,
it's a simple business.
You could do it very cheaply.
If you do more, you've got
to hire different people,
you've got to have
different systems,
different inventory.
So one reason it
could be hard is
that everything is integrated.
Everything is integrated.
It would be hard--
well, interestingly enough, if
you think about General Motors,
historically, Cadillac
was focused on luxury cars
and was sort of kept
separate from the rest of GM.
In the glory years, Cadillac
delivered luxury cars.
You couldn't have the Cadillac
operation closely integrated
with the Chevrolet operation.
You have different philosophies,
you have different purchasing,
you have different
design approaches.
Cadillac, everything was focused
on a certain kind of car--
integrated, built to deliver.
You have to build a system--
as many people
did, it turns out--
to compete.
The second-- there
on the right--
capture model is cost.
You have a cost advantage.
How can you have
a cost advantage?
Well, there might be
economies of scale.
You might have
learning advantages.
You might have other
kinds of advantages.
There are lots of ways you
could have an advantage in cost.
Yeah, Andrew.
AUDIENCE: I just had a
question regarding integration.
These might be
really bad examples.
I'm just curious
where they fit in.
Like, a company like
Walmart or like Toyota that
are quite large scale,
but then again, I've
heard many things about the way
they, for example, figured out
how to have a really
integrated system
from the supplier to the end
product and all that thing.
I'm just curious, are
they simply exceptions?
Or are they doing some other
things also that I've not seen?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
Toyota is a great case.
And others may know that
system better than I do.
They combine a number
of things, but it
is an example of a system built
to do a couple of things well.
First, they built a
product development system.
It was much quicker than
American manufacturers,
and indeed, much quicker
than European manufacturers.
So they could go from concept
to model on the street quicker.
So that's the innovation
speed down there in the left.
Could you imitate it?
A lot of people tried.
There were no obvious
barriers to imitating that.
They also had some clever
ways they did manufacturing--
just in time, and the whole
Kanban and quality circles.
There was a whole
manufacturing system.
Could you copy it?
Well, a lot of people tried.
And that's what's interesting.
There was the Toyota-General
Motors joint venture
that produced-- what was it that
they produced in California?
NUMMI, yes.
And General Motors was going
to learn the Toyota system
and copy it.
Well, the cultures
were different.
And the GM workforce--
you've been doing something
some way for 30 years,
and somebody says, now
we're going to do it
this other way, that's hard.
And you have to change the
inventory control system
and your purchasing system.
Then you go to your
designers, and you've
got to change the speed at
which you produce new products
by changing that system.
I mean, I'd say Toyota
was successfully
copied over a long time.
I wouldn't say GM has
successfully copied them.
It wasn't that Toyota was
bigger than anybody else.
They were doing
a better job when
they were smaller,
certainly smaller
than the American companies.
So they got cost by developing
a manufacturing and design
system that was simply
better, and the advantage held
because even though it looked
like you could copy it,
and there were articles and
books written on how you do
the Toyota, the Japanese
system, it turned out
to be harder to put it in place
because you had to do it all.
And again, over
time, there are lots
of studies where you
see companies now
that have that approach.
But it was sustainable.
And Toyota's not in great shape.
It was sustainable in
part because of the fact
that it was a system.
You had to do the whole thing.
You couldn't just
change inventory.
You couldn't just change design.
You had to take the
whole thing, and that
meant bringing people along.
Could you do a startup that way?
Yeah, much easier to do
a startup, much easier
to take people who've never
built or designed automobiles,
and say, here's how
we're going to do it,
but then you've
got a whole bunch
of people who've never built
or designed automobiles.
So it's a nice example.
Thank you.
Anything else?
Any other comments?
OK, let's do Husky.
What's Husky's strategy?
What is it that-- we're '95--
what is it historically
Husky wouldn't do?
Mary.
AUDIENCE: So they stuck to
some of the core values,
like professionalism
and dedicated hard work.
They also devoted a lot of
stuff to the health and--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
that's a good description
of the culture, of how they
went about doing what they did.
What did they do?
What were their activities?
Did they focus?
Were they trying to do all
kinds of injection molding,
some kinds of injection
molding, low end, high end,
middle of the market?
AUDIENCE: They focused
on the PET system.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: PET
and the thin-wall business,
so they focused on two segments.
They didn't do everything.
And as you say, they had this
very interesting culture.
So we got that one.
Don't freeze again.
What distinguished those
segments from other segments?
How were the PET and
the thin-wall segments
different from other parts of
the business, other segments?
Any obvious way?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think they
were trying to-- sorry,
I forgot my name tag.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah, but
you do remember who you are.
We're good there.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think they were
trying to find segments
where a technological
advantage is sustainable,
but it actually
makes a difference.
Like the thin-wall
business, it's
like there's probably more
technological know-how
to make it, and allows you
to make the walls thinner,
and you can machine
it faster and stuff
like that, where it hadn't
been really monetized yet,
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: What
about the PET bottle business?
How is that different?
AUDIENCE: It seemed like--
I wasn't really sure.
It seemed like they
kind of wound up
in that by accident sort of.
They're, like--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, think about.
I mean there's some
nice description of--
suppose you're
doing Coke bottles,
and you're running this
incredibly rapid bottling
apparatus.
And you produce the bottles
and you fill the bottles
under pressure.
What matters a lot?
Quality, maybe, defects,
maybe, because when
a bottle explodes and
you've got to stop the line,
that's terrible.
So performance and technology
matter in those segments.
AUDIENCE: They're not making
the blow molded machines, only
the preformed.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, but you
want to make those
free of defects.
AUDIENCE: Because when
you blow them up--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: When
you blow them up, yeah.
I think there's a number
in the case about sort
of typical defects
in one of theirs
versus typical defects
in competitors.
And it's a big difference.
And the story is when
you blow them up,
and then you fill
them under pressure,
and they explode and stop a
bottling line, that's terrible.
So if you can deliver
product that won't do that,
you've got an advantage.
OK.
So it's segments where
performance matters,
where technology is useful.
One of the things that
comes out in the case--
you have to read it kind
of closely to get this,
but it buys a lot of stuff.
It makes the molds, but
it buys a lot of inputs,
more than its competitors.
Any obvious reason?
Catherine.
AUDIENCE: Well, doesn't the
case that their campuses
are very centralized.
And it goes back to the
culture, their employees
are generally very happy there.
So it said that they
buy a lot of their molds
from people who generally
were former employees so
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So they
buy a lot from former employees,
yeah.
So that's part of the
ecosystem, as the phrase goes.
But as focused as they are
on technical excellence
of their machines,
could they do that
for everything, all the inputs?
AUDIENCE: Instead of trying
to just manufacture products,
they have a focus on
service and the entire--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
They focus on--
AUDIENCE: --package, basically.
So they try to specialize
more because then they
can provide more services
throughout the company so that
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
they have technical people
out in the field.
So they can provide a
great deal of service,
and sort of co-engineering
with their clients.
And they're in segments
where that matters.
And trying to do that for
all of the components,
and trying to hyper-engineer
all of their components
would spread them a
little thin, I think.
And I think that's
one reason why
they make fewer inputs
than their competitors,
because they've decided to focus
on the parts of the business
where performance and quality
and technology matter.
What's the answer to that?
They make some molds,
particularly for PET.
They offer hot runners, and a
variety of other things that
competitors don't.
Any reasons why?
Wyatt.
AUDIENCE: It said in the
reading with the hot runners was
they were selling the
hot runners to Gillette
or whatever, but Gillette
wasn't using their actual mold
machines.
They're using hot runners.
And then later on,
they were able to grab
a contract with Gillette
before the actual [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
it's part of the system.
Being good at that
adds to performance
and gives you a business edge.
And they're very tightly
focused on these two segments.
So you want to make everything
you can for those segments.
You want to not worry
about the inputs.
And it's made a lot of money.
The case makes it clear--
it's grown like gangbusters.
It's got a return on equity
of something like 40%.
Why, at least until recently,
hasn't anybody copied them?
What are the barriers
to imitation?
What has made this
strategy sustainable,
at least for a while.
Nothing's forever.
Brendan.
AUDIENCE: They have a huge
technological advantage.
Their machines are a
lot more expensive.
There's a deep
knowledge base there.
So it's hard to copy the
kind of quality machines
that they produce.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But you
could imagine they don't--
nobody talks about
patents, though.
We don't hear patent barriers.
So you could imagine they have
the only advanced manufacturing
center.
They've set up a
little think tank--
I don't know how little it is.
They set up a think
tank to do R&D. Why
don't other people do that?
AUDIENCE: They don't
want to invest the money.
They'd rather spend the money
elsewhere, not have that cost.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So this is part of--
well, let me push you
on that a little bit,
because they're
making so much money.
They're growing
like gangbusters.
They're making so much money.
Wouldn't you imitate
them if you could?
I mean, so yeah, you got to
set up a manufacturing center.
These are big companies.
Mannesmann is a big company.
AUDIENCE: That's why
companies eventually
did kind of get into the
markets that they were selling.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
They saw it, yeah.
AUDIENCE: They sold
cheaper machines
that can do the same job,
maybe not to the same quality
but close.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And
try to come in on price.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't the
kind of customer,
though, that's
concerned about quality
and is willing to pay more
for it, like it would make
more sense it would go with the
company that had been doing it
for longer and kind of has the
history and reputation, rather
than a company that has
just copied their technology
and is getting that
niche of the market
and doesn't have the reputation.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And
they really sort of built
the company to do
this, haven't they?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Well, my guess would
be that if you try to imitate,
you're effectively
increasing competition
that does make the business
not as profitable as it
would be otherwise.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So the
segment may not be that big,
you're saying.
And so you'd have to
do the numbers to say,
is there room for two
of us to play this game?
Maxwell.
AUDIENCE: I think
also it has a lot
to do with the
culture of the company
and you needed that
culture to make machines.
It's hard to switch
an entire culture.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, the culture
is sort of part of it, is
an intriguing part of it,
isn't it?
They've got a peculiar culture.
I want to come back to that.
Charlotte.
AUDIENCE: Also, the
fact that we said
they're only focusing
on this one thing,
whereas other companies
that were also
in the mold-making business
focused more widely.
Even when they started
to come into this area,
they sort of added onto
machines they already had,
instead of actually changing
into the same company.
Nobody shut down all
their other manufacturing
and focused specifically
on these two things.
They just incorporated it into
what they were already doing.
Maybe companies
[INAUDIBLE] they calculated
what it would take for
them to get to the point
where Husky was.
It would just have
changed their [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So this would sort of
be a little bit of the
reverse of Continental
versus Continental Light.
This would be like,
well, they tried it.
This would be like
grafting a luxury car
business onto
Volkswagen, or as Toyota
did, doing Lexus, which
they set off to one side
because you really couldn't do
the mainstream Toyota business
and the Lexus business
under the same management.
So part of it is they
really built it for this.
Do you think it has higher
or lower than average costs?
That's pretty clear, I think.
Matthew, what do you think?
You think Husky's a high
cost operation or a low cost
operation?
AUDIENCE: Well, they're high
in the sense of charging--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No,
not in terms of high price
but in terms of their cost.
Even though they've got
this lab on the side,
they've got this advanced
manufacturing center.
They've got day care.
They're very ecologically good.
AUDIENCE: They're charging high
scores that nobody can produce.
[INAUDIBLE] So I'm
saying low in comparison
to what they're charging.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That
may be, but in comparison
to their competitors?
AUDIENCE: They're
higher, because they're
producing higher quality.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: They're
And if you think about the
culture and everything else,
this is not a
company that skimps.
This is not a
They invest in R&D. They
invest in technology.
They invest in their people.
Do you think that's
important, the culture?
Is that a key part of
the story, do you think?
Not sure I know the
answer to this, but yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think it is.
Just you mentioned
before, it's something
you can get up in the
morning and go to work for.
It keeps people motivated, keeps
your workforce working hard.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Even
getting your T-square--
imagine T-squares-- even getting
your T-square straightened
on your desk, you think?
I mean, neatening your
code when you're gone.
It's an interesting
culture, I have to say.
Matthew, you're
raising your hand.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
they said in there
that whenever they
extended day care hours,
it was a kind of thing
to make them work harder,
not just for extended day
care hours for the kids.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
they're not doing charity,
are they?
But they have a particular
culture of we value our people.
We value the environment.
We value excellence, which
would be a tough culture
to sustain if they were aiming
for the low end of the market.
If you're aiming for the
low end, that's tough.
If you're aiming
for the high end,
it's like Ritz-Carlton Hotels
aim for a particular kind
of service.
And their code is
ladies and gentlemen
served by ladies and gentlemen.
If you're going to treat
your people like ladies
and gentlemen, you're going to
have higher costs than if you
treat them like pond scum.
You will also, with some
luck, get better service.
So this is a culture that
really does aim high.
Would you like to work there?
Show of hands-- who'd like
to work for this company.
OK, who would find
it really awful?
Charlotte would not like
her T-square straightened.
Neither would Maxwell.
I mean, it's for some
people and not for others.
It's autocratic.
The boss runs it.
One of the questions that's
suggested for discussion
is, could you do this
company without Shapp
in charge, Schad, rather.
Could you do this
without an autocrat
in charge, such a strong
culture, such a tight focus?
Not obvious.
OK.
What else do I want to do?
This is some numbers, which I
don't expect you to have done.
And I should have
made this clear
because you can do a fair
amount of work on the numbers.
And I'll illustrate
this kind of analysis.
For products like this,
it is often useful--
and energy products, a lot of
them come into this category,
like light bulbs--
you can do the demand analysis
by simply turning yourself
around and thinking
about this as a buyer.
If you were a buyer
producing bottles,
what would you be willing
to pay for a Husky
system versus some other
system, given the parameters?
And that gives you a sense
of what Husky can charge,
given other people's.
It's easier when it's something
like we're making bottles.
It's a little harder when
we're making Priuses,
because you don't know
what the willingness
to pay for intangibles is, or
hardwood interiors in a car.
That you can't sort of read
off the process figures.
But for something
like light bulbs,
for something like injection
molding machines, you can say,
OK, I'm running a factory.
What would I buy at
different prices,
and turn the analysis around.
And I'll just show
you the results.
These aren't my numbers, these
are somebody else's numbers,
but it's useful for
this kind of analysis.
You basically want to
say, start with the rival.
What would it cost in terms
of the machine, maybe the fact
that you've got to get more
machines because it's not
as productive, the
fact that maybe it
takes more energy, the fact that
it takes more raw materials--
what would it cost you--
this is called p star--
to do what you'd get out of
a Husky system for price p?
There's enough in the
case you can do this,
if you're very ambitious, for
thin walls and for PET systems.
This is a calculation
for thin wall.
The competitors-- use
margarine containers--
the competitor's system
has a longer cycle time,
it produces heavier components,
a heavier weight container.
It costs less.
So to get the same
output, again,
this assumes you
have a large factory,
you'd need 1 and 2/3 competitor
machines to get as much
as out of a Husky machine.
That means 1 and 2/3
times 350 is 408.
There's also a resin saving,
because the Husky container
is lighter.
So to replace a
$400,000 Husky machine,
you'd have to do $408,000
worth of competitor equipment
plus extra resin per year.
That's a willingness
to pay analysis.
So that says Husky
could, depending
on how the competitor
discounted, and depending
on how much the
competitor produced,
Husky could charge
even more than $400,000
and would still be
the machine of choice.
This is the kind of
analysis you would
expect a buyer to do, deciding
what kind of machine to buy.
And it's the kind of
analysis you'd expect Husky
to do in thinking about price.
In the past, I've taught a
pricing course here at Sloan.
And my favorite case is a
case about contact lenses
for chickens.
And it's a great pricing case
because the contact lenses
for chickens cost nothing.
You put them in the chicken
for about $0.25 a chicken.
They cost about a penny.
And they keep the
chickens, if they work,
from pecking each
other to death.
And if you do the
calculation, you
find those lenses are
worth about $4 apiece--
made up number, but
very, very high.
And most people in the
class immediately say, well,
it cost $0.25, so what we'll
do is we'll market up to $0.30.
And the answer is no.
If you do the willingness
to pay answer,
you can mark it up to
$3 as long as you've
got the patent monopoly on it.
The buyer would be
willing to pay $3
rather than do without it.
And in fact, if it's worth
$4 on this kind of analysis,
you charge $3 and they're happy.
So this is a kind
of analysis you
can do for industrial products.
That's a great case,
except as it turns out,
the contact lenses fell
out of the chickens.
The chickens plucked each
other to death and the firm
went broke.
But still, it's a
great case to teach.
It fails only the
realistic test.
This says the more containers
somebody wants to produce,
and the lower their
discount rate,
the better the Husky system is.
This is a similar analysis, a
willingness to pay analysis,
for a PET preform system.
And again, the Husky
container weight is lower.
The cost is lower,
takes up-- well,
I'm going to have to go back.
The key things you
see will turn out
to be the energy savings
and the resin savings.
So what you get here is it
produces a lighter container,
so there's a resin saving.
It's more efficient, so
there's an energy saving.
There's also a little
floor space saving.
So it's the same thing--
to replace a Husky system
costing $1.2 million,
you'd need to spend more
capacity and more yearly cost.
So again, when you think
about an industrial product,
this is the sort of
analysis you go through.
When you're a buyer you do
it, and when you're a seller
you do it.
Now again, the analysis
may be different
for different customers.
This is a case where you're
assuming that, again, I can--
where have I got it?
Yeah, I need 1.34 rival systems
to replace a Husky system
because the Husky system
is more productive.
Well, depending on how
big the factory is,
that may or may
not make any sense
because they don't
come in fractions.
If it's a large thing, yeah.
If the typical customer
has one system,
then the analysis is
going to be different.
OK, any questions about
this kind of analysis?
Folks with an
engineering background,
this sort of ought to
come pretty naturally,
just working out
on a spreadsheet.
What would you do if
you didn't buy ours?
How would you do it?
What would it cost?
Is there a gap?
So the answer to this
is, at least as of 1995
before troubles begin,
Husky systems are worth--
I mean, we're charging $1.2
million for the system,
but to replace it,
you'd have to spend
$1.3 plus $500,000 a year.
So in one sense, we are leaving
a little money on the table.
In another sense, you have
to leave a little money
on the table because these
are approximate calculations.
But the answer is, Husky's
systems justified their premium
price going into 1995.
The electricity savings
were not a trivial part
of the reason, at
least for PET preform.
Is this reasonably
straightforward,
how you would think
about doing it--
just engineer it one way,
engineer it the other way,
and check the costs,
all the costs?
We're now in 1995.
What's gone wrong?
It's the summer of '95.
They had a great year.
They're depressed.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Resin
costs are increasing.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK,
resin costs are increasing.
That's leading to a
decrease in demand.
Is that likely to be a temporary
or a permanent situation,
do you think?
Temporary, yeah.
It's going to be disequilibrium.
We've seen it before.
It's a commodity chemical.
They just have a
capacity shortage.
So we wouldn't get too
twitchy about that.
Anything else, Matthew?
AUDIENCE: A lot of
competing companies
have noticed their
success and are
starting to step in and try
to take some market share.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Now we got a problem.
That's more serious.
And these guys have been
through resin shortages,
and they don't
have a lot of debt,
and they'll probably
get through this one.
In fact, I think it fixed
itself within a year, maybe two.
But the lower cost
competitors going
after your prime customers
with lower costs--
that's troublesome.
So let's look at this two ways.
Let's look at it from the point
of view first of a competitor.
Suppose you're one of
those low cost competitors.
You know Husky's
going to do something.
What do you think
Husky is going to do?
One question is
what will they do,
and what would you think they
would do as a competitor?
And the other is what would
you recommend they do?
Those may be the same if
they're as smart as you are.
But they may not be.
Any thoughts about
you're a competitor.
What do you think Husky does?
Sam.
AUDIENCE: Talk to
their customers
and stress the quality
of the product.
Because these guys
are new, and they're
doing low cost, but
the only way they
do that is they're
cutting corners.
Like, our product's
more expensive,
but you've worked
with us for years.
You know it's trustworthy,
and just [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you think what
they would do would be to--
because they've always
been about technology,
and technological
leadership, and quality,
they're just going to
double down on that.
They're going to do
more communication.
They're going to
do more innovation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: They're
going to ride the same horse.
AUDIENCE: That's what
I think they should do.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: What
do you think they will do?
AUDIENCE: Probably, I
feel like the first thing
they may try and do
is lower their costs,
drop their prices a little bit.
I don't think that's
what they should do,
but that's what [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Why do
you think they will do it?
You had me sold.
You had me sold that
given their whole culture,
and given the way the company's
been built, that they would
double down on innovation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I feel like it's
easier to lower [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It's easier
to lower price in response.
AUDIENCE: I don't think
that's the right thing at all.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Philip,
what do you think they will do?
AUDIENCE: They'll
probably lower the price,
because [INAUDIBLE] willingness
to pay of the buyers is
probably going to decrease
because of these low-cost
competitors--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Because what?
AUDIENCE: Because the
low-cost competitors arising.
So the cost of replacing their
product is less of an issue.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So you
think if you're a competitor,
the first thing you expect
them to do is a price cut.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
OK.
Anybody else have any
expec-- because that's
the natural response to a
low-cost entrant is to come
down a bit anybody else?
David.
AUDIENCE: I would not expect
them to cut their prices,
just because that kills them.
That's like a
slippery slope thing,
where their customers will not
be willing to pay the higher
prices.
And they can't afford to sustain
their competitive advantage.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well, are
you saying what they should do
or what they will do?
AUDIENCE: I'm saying as someone,
as a competitor, especially
if I'm part of the larger
corporation like the Mann
Group, I would not expect
them to come down to my price,
rather they try to stay
high, maybe that person will
buy a little into--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So you
think that Schad would say,
I can't play a price
game with these guys.
I'm going to play my long suit.
I'm going to stick with
technology, and high price,
and communication, and
all of those good things.
OK, we're going to get--
at least the analysis in the
teaching note on this case
says, given what Schad did
to get through the '70s,
you might expect him to
double down on technology,
to keep innovating.
But what should he do?
I mean, there are a whole
set of things he could do.
He could cut prices.
He could cut them generally.
He could cut them selectively.
He could cut them in
different markets.
different segments.
He could enter their segments.
Husky is a little small in
terms of production capacity.
They might try to get
scaled by counterattacking.
They could cut
costs given they're
facing low-price
competition, but they've
got this culture that's
not a cost-focused culture.
It's a quality-focused,
people-focused culture.
So if you do that,
then for sure Charlotte
won't want to work
there, because not only
do they straighten your T,
they cut out child care.
They do all kinds of
other things to cut costs.
You could either raise or lower
all this stuff-- the service,
the technical
people in the field.
They've got probably
a high-priced sales
force because they're
all technical people.
You could go back to
plain, old salespeople.
You could cut out this
advanced manufacturing center,
which nobody else has got.
You could stop
working on research,
or you could do more
of all of those.
Whoa, that was cute--
bad button.
You could decide
that there really
are scale economies in
building your own inputs
instead of buying them.
You could try to
integrate upstream.
Or you could do things
I haven't thought of.
So instead of what would
they do, what should they do?
Sam, you had were
doing a should.
You were saying--
AUDIENCE: I was saying they
should focus on communicating
advantage to customers.
And I also think they
probably should raise spending
on technology.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And
quality and all that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Because
that's what they're good at.
OK.
Max, where are you going?
AUDIENCE: I think they
should do an analysis of who
their main customers are.
And they only make a
couple 100 machines a year.
So if all of those
machines are going
to the same customers
or similar customers
and they can probably
bank on loyalty,
then they should focus on
communicating the advantages
because they can sell that.
But if a lot of
those machines are
going to new companies that are
trying to look to reduce costs
initially, then they
might want to think
about cutting costs to stay
competitive in that market.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So that's interesting.
So if it's the same
customers, then it's
an advantage to the customer
to have only one supplier,
to have Husky
machines throughout.
So if the growth is coming from
sales to customers that already
have Husky machines, you could
stress the fact that look,
you've got one supplier.
You've only got to have
one set of spare ports.
You've only got to call one
person when it breaks down.
Be a Husky shop.
But you're right--
it might be different
if they were new people and they
worry more about upfront cost.
OK.
Anybody else?
Any other approaches?
Erica.
AUDIENCE: Would it be unusual
to look into cutting costs
while maintaining quality?
So I guess investing
research into cutting cost
but maintaining high quality.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, can you
cut manufacturing costs or you
cut out the daycare center?
You wouldn't cut
out the daycare.
AUDIENCE: No, no.
[INAUDIBLE] manufacturing costs,
like how to produce things
more efficiently.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So you'd
focus on manufacturing costs.
Would you also raise--
this is a fair amount
of cost in here,
having this high-priced
field force,
this advanced manufacturing
center, the spending
on innovation.
That's a cost.
Would you cut costs
there or would you
cut costs to focus on
manufacturing cost?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I
guess I was focusing
on manufacturing costs.
I mean, those--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Daycare center stays,
but we're going to really
try to get these things built
more cheaply.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
And then would you use
that to cut prices?
AUDIENCE: You could.
I mean, if cutting prices
reflects lower quality--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That would be bad.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But you could also
stress that you have
better quality machines or--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Jacqueline.
AUDIENCE: I was going to say I
agree with that, that you could
use that to cut prices,
but at the same time still
highlight the quality of the
product and that advantage.
You could do both strategies.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
Anybody has-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'd say increased
services at point of purchase,
so they offer free installation
or servicing of full Husky
machines or whenever you buy new
ones, or something like that,
to focus when they're
going to buy a machine,
they're going to
have it for a while.
So focus right on that point.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
that's costing me money.
So how am I going
to get it back?
Or am I not?
AUDIENCE: Customer
loyalty-- you're
going to sell those machines.
I guess you have to weigh
that kind of back and forth,
but hopefully end positive.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah,
I mean, one approach here
is to say, "Game over."
I made a lot of money before
people came into my segment,
and I'm not going to make
that kind of money again.
So what I want to
make sure is that I
maintain a position through
high service and whatever,
and don't get swamped.
I kind of niche myself
even a little more.
Charlotte.
AUDIENCE: Well,
I think that they
are a very different company
than their competitors.
They're focusing on this kind
of assembly line manufacturing
that allows them to
specialize products
for what their consumer wants.
So they can focus on that, and
even take that a little bit
further.
And maybe if there's a
huge price difference
than what their competitors
are now charging
to modify their machines.
And what they have
been charging,
they could cut price a
little so they're still
a high quality company, higher,
more luxury, but not as much.
Because they were charging
really, really high premiums,
too.
They could just change that.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: They
could come down a bit.
I mean, although
the premiums seem
to be justified based
on that analysis.
Everybody over here?
Pedro.
I tend to look left.
So you need to wave your hand.
AUDIENCE: At the
beginning, I was also
thinking of the manufacturing
costs of the machines.
Are those more energy efficient?
So that's [INAUDIBLE]
production costs.
That's what I was thinking.
But then I was also
thinking, just thought
of maybe expanding the
market a little bit.
Because the other companies
produce more types of plastics.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So maybe
go into some other segments, OK.
Let me give you a few thoughts.
They have a lot of choices here.
And it's interesting.
Looking at this whole menu,
one of the things I must
say that struck
me is before 1995,
this is a great example of how
all the pieces fit together.
They focused on a segment.
They figured out
that that segment
cares about performance.
They're all about performance
and technical excellence.
They got a culture
that fits with that.
All the pieces fit together.
It's IKEA.
It's Southwest Airlines.
And comes now this
difficult time.
Can you make the
things fit together?
So a couple of choices--
their basic options-- I
mean, you can try to can try
to increase--
Netstal is one of the
entrants, you will recall.
You can try to increase
willingness to pay.
You can think
about more service,
more R&D. The question
Schad has to ask himself,
one of the questions, is,
is there room for that?
Differentiation makes you
money if it's cost effective.
So the question is,
how much more service--
what would you get
from increased service?
The question of thinking
about who your customers are--
are they repeat?
Is this the same
people expanding?
Is it new people?
What's the return to that?
You could improve
the cost position.
Remember these two
basic approaches--
you can differentiate,
you can lower cost.
Can you cut cost
and still deliver?
If you cut the perks,
cut the sales force,
will you affect the culture?
Can you continue to deliver if
you do an aggressive cost cut?
And you can cut margins.
They've got pretty good margins.
They've got room to cut margins.
But to become the low-cost
producer-- probably not.
They could go after
other segments.
They only serve part
of the business.
They could grow by
going to other segments.
But given that they're
a high-cost company
and have a particular culture,
the question you'd have to ask
is, does that fit?
Can we do that?
And then you'd like the
whole package to fit.
And at this point,
how old was Schad?
Schad was 67 in 1995.
So someone in that age
bracket, let me just say--
he obviously has to think
about what am I handing off?
Am I going to create something
that's going to go on?
Because he's not going
to be leading it.
Well, one assumes he's not going
to be an active participant
for another 20 years.
So what he did was
actually quite drastic.
I don't know whether
this is right or wrong,
but this is what he did.
They went into other niches.
They moved out.
They increased their
manufacturing capacity
substantially.
They thought they were
too small for scale,
so they added capacity.
They cut prices dramatically in
response to low-price entrants.
Probably isn't going
to keep them out.
They worked to cut costs.
Cutting prices, it
was argued, was a way
to put pressure on costs and
hope you can keep the culture.
You basically say to
your people, look,
we're getting killed on price.
We've got a match,
and the only way
we're going to make any
money is if we can find a way
to get the cost down.
But they didn't decrease
R&D. They didn't decrease
the manufacturing center.
They didn't decrease
the sales force.
They began to build
more in-house.
And they had an IPO, sold
off the company in 1968.
How well do you think
this package worked?
Say in words-- not so well.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, also in
hindsight, I would
argue that if you'd have an
organization in the [INAUDIBLE]
as well.
So I would argue that the
low-cost manufacturers
in the US get undercut
by Chinese manufacturers.
And the best way
to stay competitive
was to stay high
cost, high quality.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
I mean, it's a curious
mixture, isn't it?
Because the company was built
for high cost, high quality.
And they tried to
position themselves
as the high cost, high quality
firm across the market in all
of these niches, even though
in a bunch of the niches,
quality wasn't that important.
So I've seen numbers
through 1999,
and they continue to grow
because the business grew.
Their profitability
was not terrific.
It was pretty erratic because
they're changing the company
rather dramatically.
And you can't get
any more numbers
because they went
private last year.
So their website now is
just an advertisement
for their technology.
There are no numbers
available because they're
a privately held company.
They're still in
Bolton, Ontario.
Questions, comments,
reactions, thoughts?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did they go private
by some sort of buyout
because of poor performance?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Their website doesn't say,
we went private because
we were performing poorly.
The website just says, such
and such a private equity firm
bought them.
I don't think that's
implausible, but I don't know.
It's not implausible
that this strategy--
that a private equity firm
said this strategy is a loser,
and we can make this
firm more profitable
by changing strategy.
But I don't know that.
OK, see you all next time.